Hallo und willkommen zurück zur Kursreihe über den Variational Quantum Eigensolver.
Mein Name ist Victoria Lipinska, und in diesem Video tauchen wir ein in die Frage, wie man
ein gegebenes VQE-Problem so darstellt, dass der Quantencomputer es versteht.
Ein quantenchemisches Problem wird typischerweise in Form von Energien
des Systems ausgedrückt.
Den Operator, der diese Energien beschreibt, nennen wir den Hamiltonoperator.
Zuerst müssen wir ihn quantisieren.
Das heißt, ihn in der Sprache der Quantenchemie ausdrücken,
die formal als zweite Quantisierung bezeichnet wird.
Wenn der Hamiltonoperator Fermion-Wechselwirkungen beschreibt, zum Beispiel
die Energie von Elektronen in Spinorbitalen, sprechen wir
von einem fermionischen Hamiltonoperator – das ist unser Ausgangspunkt für heute.
Qubits haben jedoch ihre eigene Sprache.
Die Operatoren in der qubit-Welt werden durch die Pauli-Operatoren beschrieben.
Unser Ziel ist es daher, die fermionischen Operatoren
in qubit-Operatoren auszudrücken.
Es gibt eine einfache Eins-zu-eins-Entsprechung zwischen
den Null- und Eins-Zuständen bei Fermionen und qubits.
Die Abbildung zwischen den Zuständen ist daher ebenfalls unkompliziert.
Die Abbildung der Operatoren ist jedoch etwas komplexer.
Fermionische Hamiltonoperatoren werden mit Erzeugungs- und
Vernichtungsoperatoren ausgedrückt.
Unsere Aufgabe ist es also, es dem Quantencomputer einfacher zu machen,
den Hamiltonoperator zu verstehen.
Wir werden mathematische Werkzeuge einsetzen, um einen fermionischen Hamiltonoperator
mit gates auf einen qubit-Hamiltonoperator abzubilden.
Anders gesagt: Wir übersetzen zwischen
der quantenchemischen Sprache und der quantencomputerischen Sprache.
Stell dir zwei Ketten vor – eine mit Fermionen,
also in der Sprache der Quantenchemie,
und eine mit qubits, also in der Sprache des Quantencomputers.
Auf den ersten Blick wirkt die Abbildung doch straightforward, oder?
In beiden Fällen sehen wir Systeme mit zwei Niveaus.
Bei Fermionen gibt es entweder ein Fermion im Zustand
oder gar kein Fermion.
Und bei qubits haben wir entweder Zustand 0 oder Zustand 1.
Es ist aber etwas komplizierter als das.
Der Unterschied zwischen einer Kette von qubits und einer Kette von Fermionen
ist etwas fundamental Physikalisches: die sogenannte Austauschsymmetrie.
Zwei Fermionen können niemals denselben Zustand besetzen.
Bei einer Kette von qubits ist das jedoch völlig anders.
Zwei qubits können beide im selben Zustand sein,
denn ein qubit ist kein Fermion.
Wir müssen nun einen Weg finden, zwischen den beiden Ketten zu übersetzen.
Bereits 1928 zeigten zwei Forscher, Jordan und Wigner,
dass fermionische Operatoren für die gesamte Kette
exakt durch qubit-Operatoren dargestellt werden können.
Das ist die direkteste Abbildung für einen Quantencomputer.
Man kann damit zum Beispiel die Besetzung
eines Orbitals auf den Spin eines einzelnen qubit abbilden.
In der Praxis liefert diese Abbildung für einen Hamiltonoperator eine gewichtete Summe von Pauli-Operatoren.
Das ist eine sehr wichtige Tatsache, die du dir merken solltest,
und wir werden darauf im nächsten Modul zurückkommen, wo wir besprechen,
wie variational circuits auf dem Quantencomputer ausgeführt werden.
Die obige Abbildung bedeutet, dass wir bei, sagen wir,
14 fermionischen Operatoren das Problem auf 14 qubits abbilden würden.
Zum Glück gibt es clevere Methoden, die Anzahl der qubits zu reduzieren
und weniger Quantenressourcen zu nutzen, um bessere Ergebnisse vom Quantencomputer zu erzielen.
Bei einem molekularen System kennen wir typischerweise
bestimmte physikalische Symmetrien des Hamiltonoperators,
zum Beispiel ist die Gesamtzahl der Elektronen fest.
Diese Information lässt sich nutzen, um die Problemgröße zu reduzieren,
ohne relevante Information zu verlieren.
Diese Technik nennen wir die Active-Space-Reduktion.
Sie ermöglicht eine Reduzierung der Ressourcen – konkret der Anzahl der qubits –
noch vor der qubit-Abbildung wie der Jordan-Wigner-Transformation.
Dieser Schritt berechnet einen effektiven Hamiltonoperator
und erlaubt es uns dadurch, weniger qubits zu verwenden.
In unserem Beispiel mit 14 Orbitalen
reduziert diese Technik die Anzahl der qubits auf nur noch sechs.
Wir können diese Reduktionen noch weiter treiben.
Es gibt verschiedene Abbildungen,
die etwas aufwendiger sind als Jordan-Wigner.
Das bekannteste Beispiel ist das Parity-Mapping.
Das Parity-Mapping bildet nicht die Besetzung der Orbitale auf die qubits ab,
sondern die Parität der Orbitale auf einzelne qubits.
Auf die mathematischen Details gehen wir hier nicht ein,
aber wichtig zu wissen ist, dass dieses Mapping zusätzliche
Redundanzen enthält, die genutzt werden können, um zwei weitere qubits zu entfernen.
In unserem Beispiel mit 14 Orbitalen reduziert sich die Anzahl von 14 qubits
auf 6 qubits durch die Active-Space-Reduktion und dann auf 4 qubits
durch die Zwei-qubit-Reduktion im Parity-Mapping.
Lass uns kurz noch eine weitere Transformation erwähnen.
Eine weitere häufig verwendete Abbildung zwischen der fermionischen
und der qubit-Darstellung ist die Bravyi-Kitaev-Transformation.
Die Bravyi-Kitaev-Transformation nutzt qubits, um die Information
sowohl über die Besetzungszahl als auch über die Parität des Quantenzustands zu kodieren.
Die Bravyi-Kitaev-Transformation kombiniert Besetzungszahl- und Paritätsinformation:
Für eine molekulare Orbitalbasis der Größe N
werden wiederum N qubits verwendet.
Die in jedem qubit gespeicherte Information
variiert jedoch je nachdem, um welches qubit es sich handelt.
Das heißt: Wenn der Index des qubit gerade ist,
speichert es die Besetzungszahl des entsprechenden
Orbitals – genau wie bei der Jordan-Wigner-Abbildung.
Ist der qubit-Index ungerade, speichert der qubit die Parität einer bestimmten
Menge von Besetzungszahlen. Die Bravyi-Kitaev-Transformation ist am effizientesten,
wenn die Anzahl der qubits einer Zweierpotenz entspricht.
Das Bravyi-Kitaev-Mapping kombiniert die Vorteile von Jordan-Wigner
und der Paritätstransformation.
Es reduziert die Anzahl der qubits, auf die jeder Hamiltonoperator-Term wirkt,
was für die Quantensimulation wichtig ist, da Terme,
die auf eine große Anzahl von qubits im Hamiltonoperator wirken,
längere circuits für ihre Simulation benötigen.
Das bedeutet, dass die circuit-Tiefe
mit der Bravyi-Kitaev-Transformation reduziert wird und wir im Allgemeinen
bessere Ergebnisse mit der Hardware erzielen können.
Das ist eine Verbesserung gegenüber der Jordan-Wigner-Transformation,
die zu einem Hamiltonoperator der Ordnung N qubits führt.
In diesem Video haben wir also Methoden untersucht, um
einen fermionischen Hamiltonoperator auf einen qubit-Hamiltonoperator abzubilden.
Im nächsten Video sehen wir, wie man am besten den Zustand
und eine Variationsform oder einen circuit auswählt.
Bis dahin!